[Music]
hey guys welcome to just getting news
that's not really just cutting news
because we're talking about today I'll
make it up we're talking about streaming
service there we go yeah three Morrissey
see that extreme okay Antoine you're a
huge Star Wars fan I also like Star Wars
what we both hate new Star Wars what do
we think about Disney Plus I'm actually
kind have you have you seen how much
about manual Orion have you seen did you
guys the subject that we're gonna talk
about today is what are do we think in
the next 10 years which streaming
service is going to hold largest market
share now that we have Disney Plus and
Hulu if you're magnet flick Netflix so
many like and an apple just came out
with the Arecibo bow by the way aren't
you so glad that there's this cord
cutter movement where it's like let's
save money and then you gotta buy five
different streaming services yeah yeah
grant people people are doing is that
like some one person will like buy one
thing like I here's your password for
this one one person while you look at
that bring up bringing people together
it's gonna go back to just cable like
they're gonna be like we should've been
a service that has hulu amazon why don't
we just combine all your best like
streaming services together under one
thing and call it charter that's what
these do already they have like a hulu
hulu z+ and ESPN
like in one package like oh i see what
you do in here [ __ ] I've heard this
before all those channels they owned
lakes you guys sat down and did the math
for what your monthly bill will be if
you're having all of them have no idea
oh it's gotta be like 200 I don't know
for Disney Plus to be the one why are
you thinking it's gonna be the king do
Disney have a hand in everything now
yeah yeah
maybe secretly some studio like
specifically Disney though cuz it's
funny cuz Disney's whole image is like
family-friendly but they're just like
we've got like a 51% stake did you know
what is he did not like that box that he
was put in like he actually wanted to go
I think he watched him not 12 hear him
in what some other one of those like
like wanting to be that was like really
like broke down or whatever he's like I
can't really make that right now because
everybody thinks I'm like the cartoon
dude or ever and like I think it was
like he actually was kind of I just
grunt told about not being able to he's
like I don't want to do kitchen I want
to do action movies don't think he's
like don't they know I hate Jews and I
beat my wife seen what dr. Seuss wanted
to do more adult oh yeah never accepted
a new job she's had a really weird like
personal life too I was reading I was
like yo this dude's kind of a dick
yeah he had an affair on his wife who
was dying for my oh that's the biggest
dick me yeah I was just like dr. Seuss
green eggs and ham know when she found
out she killed herself
we know you're like that's what happened
I mean dr. Seuss always creeped me out
as a kid just looking at the art and all
that oh the weird the darkness through
the art yeah twisty hills and [ __ ] JK
Rowling hi you never like dr. Seuss for
that reason no like his author picture
matched exactly what nobody looks like
actually what is he a picture the cat
inhabit my dude yes and the art was so
bad how he says that though I guess so I
feel like that's very sick when I was a
kid I was a [ __ ] art critique though
I looked at that what was your favorite
was your favorite art who's your
favorite artist a Hungry Caterpillar
[ __ ] with details really pretty
like the barreleye bad metallic and
flashy Ninja Turtles the rainbow fish
was sick
scale yeah that's it yeah okay so on the
streaming service thing Mandalorian I
haven't seen man learn yet I'm kind of
getting over Netflix I'll be very honest
unless myself show to Netflix soon and
in which case it's my favorite no but
I'm just saying I'm very bored of it
it's a stand-up special a day yeah and
everything else is kind of whatever
until stranger things and I'm over
stranger things well stranger things
sucks now every sloppy though they do
probably cool that I do enjoy like a lot
but it's like kind of far and few in
between like I [ __ ] love mine Hunter
even though Ozark season [ __ ] three
years I like umbrella canopy and I like
that Ozark and I like that strange
things and that's about it for me I'm
like terrace house viewed and yeah like
what else is cool - I know I know you do
yeah what about who does anyone use Hulu
here yeah I do baby through someone else
logging yeah it's real like TV though
right like mostly like yeah it's like TV
shows that you want to see later and
binge yeah its network TV and nobody
likes that one TV anymore
I mean like Brooklyn nine-nine is pretty
cool like I think it's the only watching
recently yeah but I but I don't do you
ever hear people this is just asking the
other day
you ever hear people like actually
recommend a network TV show and I was
like good girls on NBC and then he's
like oh but we started that what
happened the good place wasn't that a
network show and that's true yeah I
think that's a Netflix show yeah I think
it shows what I'm saying all the buzz
shows are usually Netflix it's usually
like I guess not Disney pleased to tell
Oscar marvelous mrs. nasal that's on
Amazon
I just can't get into you like I feel
like they try really hard and some of
this stuff is cool but like for the most
part like all of the Amazons man and
that highs castle is dough they need to
fire their advertising team now because
I'm with you I don't care about whatever
trailer and watching for Amazon or
whatever their advertising campaign is
it always sucks
I can't watch Jack Ryan clad you see Jim
Halpert yeah can I just leave you for
other reasons but yeah I do but like
Amazon do they pick it up it looks
terrible but I think HBO has a pretty
good streaming service like that berry
they have yeah well Game of Thrones my
Lodge in Sakura had euphoria before yeah
they're still there that in between
there like before Netflix trying to move
people from like the cinematic
experience in other guys so I feel like
they've got a solid match you know that
there have some diehard fans but when it
comes to like Netflix Disney who and
stuff like that I see like Netflix and
Disney at the top there I'm curious to
see how Apple does it but none of Apple
shows seem particularly interest how
about shows yeah they actually are not
doing too well right now the morning
show thing they made looks like [ __ ]
it looks pretentious episode yeah cuz
they launched the Apple credit card at
the same time as the show why don't
remember get a new iPhone they give you
a year for you yeah they give me that
offer I'm like even when it was free for
a year I'm just like how was the man
Lauren okay so me and Ryan I think I
don't know once you've seen a I haven't
seen episode 3 yet
I'm the uber Star Wars fan I think
you're more casual right people that
aren't Star Wars man what the [ __ ] is a
Mandalorian what the [ __ ] is true and
that's the big thing about one of those
things I think is attraction from that
particular show is that it's very much
geared to just Star Wars II because
they're doing all these turns like best
car and iron do you know what that is
what the iron best car scar best
daughter oh not best I thought you'd
like that
I'm like when are you going to move it
with the Marla fan there's like all
these little things that people are
liking like what you're laughing at
so for me I understand this [ __ ] but I
know how it works for someone else and
even me looking I could have devoted
myself to like a casual indifferent Star
Wars fan wow you're still much more into
it than I am
I'm more into it than you are but I'm
getting to your level because I'm not
into this new stuff man already like I'm
just starting to like like I am just
gonna watch my old [ __ ] and just be okay
with that
I don't give two [ __ ] about rise of
Skywalker I've never cared about
something this is what happens when you
get old like my iTunes listed and
changed since like a certain guy trapped
out I'm like are you listening to
yourself because we get so hyped for
Ozarks season 3 and that's a new thing
that thing and I'm already bad I love
trying to renew you know I know but
honestly I could like people are hype on
the mandalorian are you hype on it I'm
not high on it I think it is better than
most of us that that's been coming out
recently but I don't think I mean people
because it's been so like oh oh you hate
everything it's like a always something
greater game it I don't think it's great
I think it's just good and by the way
this is us watching it three episodes
and so who knows maybe eighth episode
it's [ __ ] like Brillion or some like
that I feel like it's still trying to
find its footing person I agree and I
think that as a whole this is what makes
me nervous for Disney because I feel
like Disney as a company should know how
to do a TV show yeah and the fact that
they're trying to find their footing
with this particular show I don't know
if that's because it's a Star Wars short
or if it's because they don't know how
to handle a streaming thing the Star
Wars in general has been trying to find
its place yeah but just in jail like
them they're parts of the Mandalorian
that I want to enjoy but other parts
that I'm like like I don't feel like
it's a spoiler but he doesn't take his
mask off right you think George Lucas is
watching this like oh my god he actively
has said that there was an interview
don't know wasn't review was um the Bob
Iger who's the partner of Disney came
out with the autobiography and part of
it was talking about how George was not
happy with what they did because he had
this whole treatment about what his like
the last like you know truly opposed to
be and they didn't do a damn thing what
can I just say though I heard I heard
part of his trilogy was gonna be sit in
a macro by micro biotic world involving
the force and know the middle I and I
know I'm serious
no wonder they use it I mean yeah
like and even JJ just came out and said
yeah he's like yeah I met with George
he's like he sure loves his
midi-chlorian so I was like holy [ __ ]
what was George gonna do you mean like a
like a little petri dish yeah all right
the minute chlorines is like a little
microscopic life-form that means you can
have the force yeah it which a lot of
fans hate because it takes away from
like the foursome a dream magic and it's
more about like a science thing so I so
I know mandalorian is like a Star Wars
egg it's a war faring culture so they
come from this planet where their
cultures based around wet beans and
imagine like space Spartans yeah so they
take so they become a lot and become
bounty hunters that's why you're boba
fett jango fett and easy think about
that race yeah so imagine like Jango
Fett don't like not Jango Fett but
imagine one of his people going off as a
[ __ ] bounty hunter just [ __ ] which
Muslim do it this time because there's
no war and also the people are kind of
broken people at this point so that's
why they all have been like we're bounty
hunters we're fighters out whatever you
do you know it reads like a [ __ ]
video game slash a nice western well if
they hire Dog the Bounty Hunter I know
well my baby Yoda is doing some good
things for them right just for that see
how memes work about it but did you hear
that Disney is banning baby Yoda memes
doing takedowns of so I guess a couple
websites have been hosting those like
jiffy or whatever and they just they
don't give it that's good advertising
they have no [ __ ] clue like whoever's
working there should all be [ __ ]
summarily fired because they're all
insane people what do you guys said
that's where the baby it okay if I'm
like all I want to see it in that spread
like wildfire
yes yeah I didn't think they'll be able
to make a bo de baby and cute but they
did they do
[ __ ] adorable looks like a [ __ ]
people love baby things like baby Groot
like when group
[Music]
we like baby makes okay and I think
Disney has that too
Disney has Marvel Disney had Star Wars
this he has even though we were saying
like we don't really know what's wrong
with this room you every day they at
least gets to save themselves I feel
like for at least a few years I think
that they're going to be they will they
will be successful because they have
money to burn they just [ __ ] fuel
this loss later until it eventually
becomes profitable how do you guys feel
about how the Game of Thrones riders
left Game of Thrones so they could write
off the other thing that's such a good
build-up mm-hmm Wow yeah they rushed it
like it was a mid turn homework hey you
want to talk about how much we hate
women apparently because we hate new
Star Wars Daenerys Targaryen character
in that whole show and they ruined until
the last two episodes I know I hear
think I'm okay with that too like you if
you criticize that then you [ __ ] like
you know she was cool you're still up
until that moment with the Bell where
it's like it wasn't explained Yeah right
why would she fight your worst case
scenario just go straight to the red key
yeah and destroy and destroy clean why'd
you have to go ahead why didn't make her
in that insane where it's like I gotta
go everybody no lie on you cuz she was
on her period yeah that's kind of need
to explain that they didn't even say it
like give it kind of did he had this
scene with Jon Snow well she's like well
it's hate Minh when he went to kiss her
cuz he's like yeah I don't want to kiss
my aunt whatever one's you like Oh will
it be love or will it still [ __ ] the
[ __ ] out of her nice you [ __ ] your
aunt Hallie a unibrow what are you
saying right I was just gonna say the
interviews that they did at the end with
them to explain what they were doing I
was like this is terrible they were
leering she was they were talking about
how she got shot out of the sky she was
like oh she just forgot the iron fleet
was there to be like this very high
integrity like yeah she's not dumb but
she was on a beard and I think like that
ending still could work like I can tell
because obviously they're working from
George's outlines you know they knew
like we knew understand that's where
he's gonna end but it wasn't the issue
of it happening it was that journey
they're like because they rushed it we
couldn't see [ __ ] De Niro
crumbling down people I always try to
say this for Breaking Bad the reason why
we are on that ride with Walton we
understand that he goes bad it's cuz
he's dead that over he breaks bad over
what 60s exactly there's a gradual
progress in areas they don't break her
bad until really like the last season
and not even that last episode Walter
killed a bad guy who was trying to kill
him and he was devastated right I mean
like and then we saw him slowly
progressed to the gun game or hurry it
says Jesse run like yeah exactly yeah so
if we would have fought with an heiress
then fine yeah you that ending is
completely fine I can see that ending
working is that in that contest what
they did know they needed more seasons
like George wanted yeah well yeah I
don't know which one's gonna win
probably Disney Plus is my have a good
footing
[Music]
[Music]